ow Rock Nation brunch or
The Hamptons party of Rick oh Michael oh
that's hard
that's full yeah it's not even a
question I don't know except because
Michael Reuben party because Jay-Z was
there anyway get the twofer yeah yeah he
might and black people are good in all
white too yeah you guys do look very
good very good at all I might do that
look very good puffy used to throw that
party though right when we were I always
thought it was Puffy's party he does the
New Year's uh Poppy's always New Years
back in the day no no he used to do a
challenge white party had you guys heard
of Michael Rubin before this doesn't he
own the 76ers
and then he started getting like
publicly famous because he really helped
to get uh Meek Mill out of jail ah son
of the helicopter off of there because
of this I heard him on all the smoke and
I was like who is this guy everybody
loves and I was like this guy seems
great like great question answers to
every question seemed honest in a way
that was like not like gross it just
seemed like I was like oh yeah I would
love this guy no I'll invite me to the
white party yeah
well I'm free next year
would you want to go one of the good
ones like what do you mean like the blue
squares or no the good whites
oh he's a blue square Blue Square yeah
um would I go yeah
would you go
are you kidding me
if I wanted to go this year but oh [__]
stops oh you can't actually Doug could
find a way yeah I just took it back I
was like no you know what if this one
would be hard but he could get it 100
you're lying if you saying put it this
way it looks way more fun than the Met
Gala oh yeah absolutely this looks like
people are getting drunk and like just
being Goofy and they're not wearing some
uncomfortable [__] outfits
yeah exactly now the only thing would be
the only thing that would make me feel
potentially uncomfortable is if I wasn't
going with anybody that I knew because I
could imagine being really isolating
yeah do you know what I'm saying but if
you had like six people there and you're
just people watching the most famous
people everybody there is people
watching yeah right and everybody there
is the most famous like in their little
sphere you think there's a few people
that are like the alpha still that
everybody's what like in My Mind Jay-Z
everybody's still looking at Jay-Z of
course and Jay's probably not looking at
that many people course yeah that's
crazy and there's somebody there that
Jay-Z is like there's like some art
collector there I hope I get to talk
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think maybe
that's the cool thing about you see
people act like fans uh to other famous
I was thinking meeting everybody like
the networking would be crazy even if
you don't get anything out of it the
opportunity deals probably get made from
that [__] he should get 10 it's like
Shark Tank this is a rich [__]
shark time yeah yeah and then you're
gonna blame the Jews for taking 10 again
I mean I would yeah how did you do that
I know how did you do everybody was even
you need to get ahead of the story when
he comes out Illuminati and then you're
like you're in the store you're the
media don't worry about it what do you
mean you control it I um I like juice
I like most Jews this one I'm not so
fond of right now you're the one who
brought it up I just said it was a good
white yeah yeah I said you know he's
Jewish I didn't come on I don't think
about that it makes sense when you say
it but we don't think about it before
I'm saying when you say it we're like oh
yeah obviously but we don't think about
it I don't see a collection of cool
black people around a white guy
there's a 99.9 chance he's a Jew
point nine percent chance yes black
people don't have good Judah yeah
because we don't most minorities don't
know we don't know
what's that are not Jewish don't want
black people around
that's probably true yeah like a really
rich like white white guy yeah Jewish
would never throw a party and then just
be like hugging up with a bunch of black
people never hang with Joel and bees
yeah it's like how do I get the [__]
away from everybody that's not a
billionaire it's really endearing that
he would hang out with so many poor
people
he would throw a party with all these
pores compared to him
relative to him he's a [__]
billionaire like Jesus okay so Jade I'm
not saying black people are poor I'm
saying they're all these people
to him jack Harlow's poor man they're
all poor like billionaires that's
[__] adorable that's how we look at
hundred ears I mean exactly like if he's
big billion I don't know how much money
he's got but if he's big billionaire he
can be hanging out with [__] Buffet
he can actually have Amazon and all
those guys that's their crew and he's
decided to hang around with uh a little
bit what's the name the baby little baby
little baby like that's cool that's
adorable 11 billion he's got 11 billion
yeah I mean that's big boy you're
looking at Jay-Z like catch up 11
billion Robert Kraft is 10. I didn't
know 10 billion most of that's probably
his NFL team though that's what's crazy
is they don't have the same valuations
NBA teams I know he's the sole owner of
the NBA team I don't think he is
wow you know so I think it's true it's
fanatics fanatics is worth tens of
billions I don't know what his share is
but yeah something else too let's say
it's 10 billion right what is 10 of 10
billion a billion that's one billion
five percent of 10 billion 500 million
dollars
that's the interest he could be making
on his money a year
so just this is when you see
billionaires doing this stuff that like
they're like that's so crazy why are
they flying a helicopter to their yacht
schultzy loopholes okay
they can't
coming back
so much is coming back that you have 500
million dollars to spend if you don't
have a drug addiction or a gambling
problem you can't spend 500 million
dollars and not have Assets in a year
yeah like think about 500 mil that's
just interest
so of course let me get the private jet
and fly a bunch of other people like I
love the fact that he's being generous I
love the fact that he's spending a few
million on this party it's nothing
interest is paying you back that's if he
has it all cash he has it in Investments
and that kind of stuff sure don't
billionaires want to be loved then later
they're afraid that the poor are gonna
rise up against them
if they were smart they would just want
to be anonymous that's why I think real
billionaires are mostly Anonymous also
by the way why don't they just go around
just giving out money but think about it
like this too mathematics went from
trading cards it's gonna become a huge
betting platform I think he had to sell
his stake in order to buy the 76ers and
now because no now he's going this to um
sports betting so this anyway makes his
brand look just that much better and
cooler oh it's a huge brand huge I mean
I'll be honest with you I think it was
last year there was one was it last year
yes and then this year those are the
only two I've ever heard of it I only
knew of a white party with puffy yeah I
had never never heard of this I never
heard until this year with this year it
feels like this has been going on for 20
years I didn't know about it yeah with
the coverage the Press coverage I know
it has been going on for quite some time
yeah because I've heard about this party
for a while yeah I don't know I'm just
saying I know it just feels and the way
that there was covid and these other
things but now it feels like dude
to get celebrities
to be in the Hamptons
in July
when they could be
in Italy or France or any or Greece like
they're choosing to be they have this is
nice don't get me wrong but you're still
in New York in July yeah you gotta you
know what I'm saying like it's not the
best time right but for them he's making
that cool again and it's now part of a
social calendar whatever it was for the
rest of Europe you're there and then you
go yeah where's everyone stay like just
hotels and [__] they rent these houses
and it's like for fifty thousand dollars
a week like it's insane does he set it
up or they they have to figure it out if
y'all figure that [__] and I'm sure he
houses a certain amount of them like I
was listening to the all the smoke
podcast and I think it was Matt Barnes
was like I got my suit ready and it
didn't sound like he had been invited
yet but well I I felt was he hadn't been
invited yet but he's like hey can I I'm
I can come right like it's just crazy to
listen to this guy and again I could be
misreading but he was like hey I got my
white suit ready and my group was like
yeah it could be misinterpreting maybe
yeah I'm curious how he managed that's
how sought after it is that's the
interest how do you manage it because
you know everybody wants to go and
there's gonna be somebody who's too
famous to ask
but not famous enough
to be invited yeah that is going to ask
you
and they're gonna say it and you're
gonna have to handle that yeah that's a
tricky thing Stephen A Smith oh that was
hilarious no what happened Steven Smith
had a video it's like why wasn't I
invited uh oh wow I mean that is kind of
true like why I want Stephen A there
yeah or do you not want the media guy
there because then it makes all the
athletes feel uncomfortable letting
loose uh but I think they know that he's
seen it all and they're still still I if
I'm if I'm an NBA player or if I'm in
any athlete if you're James Harden and
your whole reputation is you don't love
basketball you love strippers and booze
I don't even want to see the guy who's
been criticizing me for this yeah yeah
100 can't have any media there I think
it's also he likes the cool Factor so
just because Stephen A is that guy is
like nobody's looking at yellow Steve it
ain't so cool
I think Michael Rubin really likes the
cool Factor so he has all these cool
influential people because like little
babies like Steven A is cool for a
journalist
yeah but he's not he's not your point
I think how they come up with the invite
list the invite list like who has the
clout yeah yeah but then you got to tell
somebody you don't have to have it you
ain't got it but I don't think it's him
like but that person might have your
number you're gonna see them like you're
going to see them at games like you know
like that's what I'm saying
yeah that that type of [__] he might
even just say anxiety you have to just
lie or just be like it's not out of my
hands my my people handled it they got
their way I don't you know the craziest
thing is Michael Rubin probably has a
lot of close nerdy friends no he's super
close they're like sorry and he's got to
say this ain't really a party this is a
PR spend and
I unfortunately can't have you guys here
for it we're all going to go to Sandra
pay this [__] summer together and
we're going to take the Jet and it's
going to be amazing you guys are gonna
love it but this specific party has to
be done in this way and you just need to
accept that and I imagine that these
people if they're also Titans in
business are gonna go yeah I don't give
a [__] I don't even want to be in this
stupid charade like it is funny though
people always want what they don't have
the one thing a lot of billionaires are
missing is that I'm assuming so they
might be like what the [__] bro I just
think I just want to go meet these
people that's it that's all I want
billionaires probably also don't get
told no very often oh yeah so if it does
they do it probably so no billionaires
being told no bye bye it's gonna be his
like friends that like his his head
accountant that he has a personal
relationship with and that and I imagine
you have enough room
I don't know we should ask him about
that that's interesting how do you
handle the politics of it and like the
invite list to get one person to be a
domino fall for all the other people
exactly oh Jay-Z's coming like hey man
I'd love to have you come out I think a
couple people are coming out Jay-Z
whatever and then everyone's like oh
yeah exactly how did it starts how do
you get the pieces together it's like a
movie you get Tom Hanks to sign on for a
movie everybody else is easy yeah you
get Tom Brady to be the quarterback of
your your team everybody else is coming
yeah I'm playing for the minimum yep and
what is the promotional tool here is
this for Fanatics or is this for his
personal brand is it like sure you love
the fact that everyone's saying your
name as much but Fanatics is definitely
being
from this founder and CEO of Fanatics
throwing the coolest party with the
coolest people they might become brand
ambassadors and not be [__] over like
FTX I think they actually trust him as I
think a lot of these folks folks are
like oh this is aspirational [__] like
this is yeah Jay-Z's friends these are
Tom Brady's friends these are these guys
so let's let's be here and he's playing
love Matchmaker
oh yeah yeah
Tom Brady and Kim K you think that was
real I don't know rumored but you know
can't trust anything I heard there's
another rumor about him and Emily
Ratajkowski
were and I uh that's what they said
there's both those rumors are out there
from the Whiteboard oh
Tom going through it I'm going through
it
going through going through them yeah oh
yeah I know yeah going through the hits
yeah Tom I mean I don't know if he's
knocking it down in the Mansion Maybe
I mean yeah what what do you do who do
you date yeah please not Kim
I I just should be ruining too many
dudes lives I can't come on let's keep
it yeah I think yeah I think Portnoy did
a thing about that too he was just going
crazy he's like don't
but he has to
have a lot of fun with a Kardashian they
gonna have fun with you yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta be very careful yeah